[Music]
all right
hello and welcome everyone
it's ActInfLab Livestream number 46.0
and
it's June 10th 2022.
welcome to the active lab everyone we're
a participatory online lab that is
communicating learning and practicing
applied active inference you can find us
at links here on the slide
this is a recorded in an archived live
stream so please provide us with
feedback so we can improve our work
all backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome and we'll be following video
etiquette for live streams
head over to activeinference.org if you
want to learn more about live streams at
the lab or other projects that are
ongoing
all right we are here in the first
discussion the dot zero for background
and context in stream number 46.0
we are learning and discussing the paper
active inference models do not
contradict folk psychology by ryan smith
maxwell ramstead and alex kiefer
and the video just like all the videos
are is an introduction and a
contextualizer and an appetizer for some
of these ideas it's not a review or a
final word
we're going to say hi and give
introductions
then we'll be covering the roadmap and
abstract claims and aims and then we'll
head through some of the core sections
of the paper and just get some of the
key arguments down and during the dot
one and the dot two in the coming two
weeks we'll have uh open space for
asking a lot of questions for those who
wanna participate live and ask questions
as well
so
on we go
we'll start just by introducing ourself
as much or as little as we'd like and if
we want to mentioning something that
we're excited about in the paper like
what brought us to want to contribute to
this dot zero
and all start i'm Daniel i'm a
researcher in california and i think the
title says it all though there's still
more to add and it speaks to many of the
hottest
and brightest debates in active
inference which is
the rubber hitting the road with mind
and brain and body and psychology and
previous and different conceptions
i'll pass it to Dean
thanks Daniel. I'm Dean. I'm up here in
calgary
um
i think well a couple of things first of
all one of the first active
infrastructure that i was on
was a paper that ryan had written and so
i was kind of impressed with that paper
and i knew that if i sort of invested
some time in this one
stuff that i would
become
previous and
the primary thing i came where i was was
looking at
active inference from the decisioning
and uh
and the movement standpoint
sort of
seeing that's uh
looked at from
a higher order and the lower order type
of um processings
and that when i bought the time i got
the end of the paper and started looking
at the mind's world
and world's mind piece and and and
seeing where the
the potential connectors were between
sort of coming into it not
necessarily knowing that there would be
different things of active inference
much like i didn't realize there was an
extended active inference until i read
axel constance paper that was kind of
helpful and i'll pass it to jacob
hi everyone i'm jakob i'm a student from
the czech republic
and
i'm
excited to
uh
reduce my uncertainty about the
new
kind of formulation that that
um was introduced in this paper at least
it was the first time i came across it
in the active inference literature um as
you mentioned dean about the
different higher order and
lower order descriptions and how they
conceptually
map
um
to the different mathematical
mathematical formulation and also
to
the
psychological ontology
and
um
overall just discuss uh
what that what that means and um what it
might mean for um other applications as
well
and
i'll pass on to ryan
i'm yeah thanks so i'm i'm ryan smith
i'm a research associate professor at
the uh laureate institute for brain
research
um you know so i'm the
first author of this uh this paper so
you know obviously i was especially
excited about the ideas to write about
it
um or sufficiently motivated at least to
try to clarify some things that i am you
know from my perspective or sort of
common misconceptions um
so um yeah i mean you know i'm i'm
probably more gonna sit in the
background here i'll just be here to uh
you know answer questions or clarify
anything um you know if something comes
up where um something in the paper
wasn't uh wasn't sufficiently clear
because i didn't i didn't do my job well
enough so um yeah so i appreciate you
guys being with us willing to uh to talk
about it
thanks well an overall comment was we
really appreciate the clarity of the
argument and the writing and the weaving
together of the the math and the
formalisms with the argument the
rhetoric and the ontology that's
that's
prime time so we'll just jump right in
and of course anyone is welcome to share
their comments
so dean would you like to help us
contextualize with a big question
yeah so i think that there's
some questions surrounding and i'm just
going to take some of the important
quotes that i
i lifted from the paper the concern that
active infants
spoke psychology because
they do not explicitly include terms for
desires or other cognitive constructs at
the mathematical level of description
so
given that distinction
uh that there are active inference
models of motor control which need not
have desires under folk psychology and
active inference models
you have desires within folk psychology
then
worry is that it
those can
be
constructed
could you um i think when you're talking
you like turn away a little bit or move
back it kind of cuts the audio so maybe
yeah
we'll try that okay continue from the
given thank you
okay so
given the there's a distinction in
active inference models of motor control
uh which do not have desires under fox
ecology and active interest models of
decision processes which do have desires
with psychology or so as argued here
then the worry is that if active
inference models can explain cognition
without appealing to constructs it can
be mapped onto the common sense notion
of desires
and that's how to explain what that is
then this could be seen as threat or
intuitive folks i call like
oh of ourselves as agents
such a situation would also pressure the
traditional belief desire intent model
of folk psychology that is prominent in
philosophy the bdi model is a model of
human agency that explains what it means
act intentionally so for me i was
introduced to the bdi model as
yes great and and one way that i kind of
saw this big question even pulling back
a layer is like is active inference
recontextualizing reframing augmenting
building on what is already familiar in
a sense though there are many folk
psychologies and i think that could be
something we go into or is this the
displacement of some
cherished framework for some other
construct and the way that people speak
like i want the cup of coffee or
something like that are we gonna need
like a different word for an active
compatible folk psychology and
linguistics so
jacob any thoughts on that
well
um
i guess
one question i uh perhaps had
was like um
this
even this formulation of the of the
initial of the initial statement like
given this distinction of motor control
active inference and
decision processes active inference then
we have this then we have this issue
well
one thing that i was a bit uncertain
about was whether this distinction was
made to fit the distinction that's
within folk psychology like there is
some kind of
ontology for motor control
and um an ontology for decision
processes so therefore we try to um
split active inference into these two
parts
or whether there is actually
uh whether these this distinction
follows directly from
the the same mathematical formulation of
um active
great
well i think i think i think one thing
one thing to um you know to clarify i
think i think the way that this kind of
given the distinction followed by then
here
um i think could be leading to a little
bit of a misunderstanding you know so
the the idea that there's a concern
about about a threat to full psychology
um comes not from that distinction it
comes from
the the fact that there's at the
mathematical level of description it
doesn't look like there's anything in
there
that that's that's
desire-ish
right i mean that's where the worry
comes from
um it doesn't really the worry doesn't
come from the distinction between motor
control and decision processes
right the the distinction between motor
control and decision process is actually
one thing that by making that more
explicit and it actually
helps to resolve uh the concern or it
shows why it's not really a concern or
that part of the concern stems from
a failure to make that distinction
explicitly
um so so just to kind of clarify the you
know so i think the order
of the of the thought process here is a
little bit different than the way um the
way it is in the paper
thanks
helpful times and we'll clarify and go
through the argument in order to
so
uh briefly just the aims of the paper as
they presented are to
provide a brief review of the historical
progression from predictive coding to
current active inference models
and show that despite a superficial
tension when viewed at the mathematical
level the active inference formalism
contains terms that are readily
identifiable as desires and related
cognitive constructs at the
psychological level which is downstream
of that clarification of the distinction
that ryan just mentioned
and then they discuss the additional
insights offered by active inference and
the implications it has for current
debates about active inference
any other aims you'd want to add ryan
um i think this is fine at the moment i
mean i'm sure things will come up
great
and then
um claims um jakub could you read the
claims
yeah
so uh firstly that the apparent problem
posed by purely
doctastic looking constructs simply is
not a problem there do not appear to be
cases where the phenotype consistent
prior expectation in dai often called
prior preferences
will ever conflict with or make distinct
predictions than a traditional folks i
call psychological account in which
beliefs and desires are integrated to
intentions
the second claim is that
what we have referred to as dai the
partially observable markov decision
process formulation of actin
is a corollary of the fep and it can be
implemented using prediction error
minimization but there are many other
aspects of the fep and many other
theories that fall under the umbrella of
predictive processing
and
in some there are beliefs and desires in
the active inference framework
thanks and those are just a few claims
that we pulled out but many other
declarative sentences will also be
claims
um i wouldn't i wouldn't necessarily
call those the primary claims of the
paper i mean there's certainly
statements that we make but
um i think i think the idea that there
isn't uh i think the idea that the
apparent problem isn't a problem i think
that's a claim
um
and uh that it doesn't that there won't
be a conflict
with with an account where you're
combining beliefs and desires to form
intentions that's true
um
this idea about about what falls under
the predictive processing umbrella would
um
you know immediately
i wouldn't necessarily say that's
something we're arguing for in the paper
it's just
it's just um something that that
matters when you're trying to correctly
frame this kind of this kind of debate
because
um
you know predictive processing is just a
very
generic term right like like it doesn't
refer to any particular mathematical
formalism it just refers to a really
broad idea
that in some way the brain is doing some
sort of predicting um either with
respect to
resolving problems in perception or
problems in decision making and motor
control
so so there really isn't um
there's not enough uh
there's really just not enough
mathematical specificity associated with
predictive processing as a term to
really even test any predictions that it
would make right so i mean i mean what
you what you need to do is pick you know
whatever specific mathematical formalism
what actual hypothesis you're talking
about
um and you evaluate and test claims with
respect to that right so there's there
just aren't
there's aren't clear uh
like what even
uh
it's just you're predictive processing
is just too general in bank is the point
so
you know we can only really say look
under
under the current models used that are
called active inference right so these
you know partially observable markup
decision process models
um you know that that minimize expected
free energy as a way of making decisions
right those
those arguably count as one particular
right theory or or class of models
under the predictive processing umbrella
and we can evaluate claims with respect
to that model
but you know what's true of that doesn't
need to be true of you know the other
you know 20 things out there that might
um
you know might also fall under a
predictive processing umbrella so that i
mean the main point is just we need to
evaluate um
you know claims and predictions and
things like that with respect to
a specific model not with respect to a
kind of vague general category of models
thank you
okay
um
so just
rapidly through the abstract
active inference offers a unified theory
of perception learning and decision
making at computational and neural
levels of description
in this article we address the worry
that active inference may be in tension
with the belief desire intention bdi
model within folk psychology because it
does not include terms for desires or
other cognitive constructs at the
mathematical level of description
to resolve this concern we first provide
a brief review of the historical
progression from predictive coding to
active inference enabling us to
distinguish between active inference
formulations of motor control
mai which need not have desires under
folk psychology and active inference
formulations of decision processes dai
which do have desires under or sorry
within folk psychology
we then show that despite a superficial
tension when viewed at the mathematical
level of description the active
inference formalism contains terms that
are readily identifiable as encoding
both the objects of desire and the
strength of desire at the psychological
level of description
we demonstrate this with simple
simulations of an active inference agent
motivated to leave a dark room for
different reasons
despite their consistency we further
show how active inference may increase
the granularity of folk psychological
descriptions by highlighting
distinctions between drives to seek
information versus reward and how it may
also offer more precise quantitative
folk psychological predictions
finally we consider how the implicitly
cognitive components of active inference
may have partial analogues i.e as if
desires in other systems describable by
the broader free energy principle to
which it conforms
here's the roadmap
so
the dot
zeros all of them in the world wouldn't
be enough to hit every stop
so we will go through um
roughly in order of these sections
um and the section titles are listed
here but ryan what was the thought going
into the ordering or the structuring and
why there was such a
comprehensive historical and preliminary
consideration section
i mean i mean a lot of you know i mean
the vast majority of these sections are
just kind of building up background
right i mean sufficient background to
kind of see right where
where the um you know both both i think
historically where you know potential
misunderstandings might come from
um you know and also and also just
enough of the you know providing enough
of the formalism you know one part of
the formalism just kind of build on
another right to see why the um you know
to see why the the
apparent problem just isn't there
right so i mean the vast majority of
these sections are just preliminary just
kind of building up so that the reader
has the information necessary to
understand the argument i mean only only
the last couple of sections they're
really um really the meat of the
argument itself i mean so so you know
for example just section
two you know the are what we just said
from the predictive coding active
inference is just kind of highlighting
how you know these initial
brain as as implemented through
predictive coding was you know purely a
model of perception
right so then you know so then when
people but a lot of times you'll see
especially in the um you know older
literature in some philosophy literature
um you know predictive processing
somehow both refers to predictive coding
but then also is talked about as though
it's um
as though it's the same thing as active
inference
um you know or there'll be these kinds
of ideas where
um if you just extend predictive coding
as kind of a
the way it's talked about as a kind of
way of thinking about what the whole
brain does you know then all of a sudden
um you know controlling the body
ends up also just being something about
predicting what the body will do um
but but and especially when described
that way right it sounds like something
like
desire and motivation and goals and
things like that are just kind of
completely out the window and it's very
hard to make sense of what how a system
like that would even work
right um and so it's and and part of
that i think is because there's you know
some um
you know some uh
the way that certain things are written
in some of the literature can be a
little bit um confusing or it's not too
it's not too
uh hard to understand why you know these
sorts of um you know these sorts of
misunderstandings could uh you know
could happen
um but but uh but the you know section
two there was really really is to show
how you know initially right when you're
trying to move from predictive coding
again which is purely a model of
perception it's not about decision
making it's not about action selection
you know it's not even about motor
control right it's just it's just a
bayesian just a theory of how the brain
can do approximate bayesian inference
and perception
um you know how
that was initially just extended to say
hey like if the brain works this way
then you know how do you how do you get
a system that actually controls the body
using the same generic architecture
right and so then you know the story
that carl fristan you know and and
you know some other people started
trying to put together was
the story about how you can use
predictions you know descending
predictions
um if weighted appropriately right as a
way of essentially setting the target
states of the body
right like like is this kind of you know
the way you'll see it talked about is
you know i predict that my arm will be
here but really it's down here but if i
wait that correctly then it'll kind of
like you know you'll kind of control the
set point in a reflex arc to you know so
your arm kind of moves up with a
position
right but but that's
just a theory about how you can use a
descending prediction signal to
essentially act as a motor command
signal right there's nothing in that at
all that that's deciding
what that prediction ought to be right
there's nothing deciding what that what
which motor command
should should be the one right that's
getting sent down in in a
in in the
with the form of a prediction
um right so so again so even there it's
just a theory about how you can use
predictions as motor commands right like
there's no there's a very big
distinction between that and whatever
the system uh is on top of that right
that's deciding okay what motor command
what what motor prediction right do i
send
um and so just making you know making
making that clear right because around
there was this big shift right from
these from these act where from active
inference being talked about as a just
kind of a motor control process right
like a like a story about how you can
extend predictive coding
to
uh
you know also do motor commands right
like from that to
you know these larger more comprehensive
decision making models which are the
current right pump bps
and those you know which was what we aim
to show um very explicitly you know have
something that um you know in the
mathematics
it just does right it specifies the
goals of the system um it's pretty hard
to get around the fact that you need
something a system needs something like
goals right because it has to evaluate
somehow
why one decision is going to be better
than another
right the only way you can really do
that is with respect to how likely it is
to get whatever the system wants
um
so so it's just i mean in my
yeah in my view it's it's very difficult
to see how
um
how you could ever get um a system to be
able to evaluate one action is better
than another without having some sort of
target state
um
and um and so
you can call
right like the the target dates in
active inference um a type of prior
belief
but at the end of the day its functional
role is to specify what what
observations are better than what right
so i mean you can really think of active
inferences
as
using this kind of trick in a certain
sense right of specifying desired
outcomes in the form of a probability
distribution
um because that helped keep everything
belief believe me fully bayesian right
um but it's not it's not it's not
playing functional world belief right
it's encoding you know higher
probability just means right like the
better more rewarding outcome
um so so a lot of it is just
um you know kind of working step by step
through
both kind of the historical progression
so you can see where the
misunderstanding could come from and
then also through the current formalism
so that you can see exactly where those
where the you know the goal states are
encoded in terms of something with the
form of a probability distribution
thank you
the
keywords
are
active inference folk psychology
predictive processing bayesian beliefs
and desires so now we're going to jump
in
and some of the slides have a lot of
text topically arranged so we won't need
to read all the text on many of the
slides but especially if somebody wants
to pull out like one of the highlighted
sections and
like bring it to our attention that
would be awesome
so um and also ryan thanks a lot for
that great historical overview and i
think there's there's so much more to be
going into about what happened before
2015 and what happened in the last seven
years
um
in fact i think you covered many of the
key points in what you just described
here
which had to do with the development of
predictive coding framework into
understanding brain and body
is there anything that anyone else wants
to add about these points
great then
um
all discussions and um dot zeros are
like a two-way street where some people
with active inference familiarity are
learning about new ideas and frameworks
and also people who might have
familiarity with a broadly
used area outside of actin are learning
about active so for both directions on
that freeway it's important to
understand what is the target non-actin
framework that's being juxtaposed and
found concordances with active inference
so
the article is addressing the worry that
active models may be in tension with the
belief desire intention model and there
are some consequences to that
um worry
in other words um given some priors it's
a founded worry
um
would anyone like to summarize what the
belief desire intention model is
thank you daniel because you i think you
put this slide together
ryan what led you to select the bdi
model
and i wondered about um almost this
tension or paradox with like it's folk
psychology it's about what the people
think
but we're gonna do a citation and one
specific academic acronym for what
people think so is this like the main
game in town for folk psychology from an
academic perspective or what is the bdi
and what led you to select that
rather than like a small portfolio of
alternate folk psychologies
um i think i think that the you know
belief desire intention model is just um
a very kind of you know generic button
but also um you know widely known right
like account of you know trying to
capture full psychology and you know
it's kind of the it's a it's a
it's a major
um sort of target of uh a lot of
discussion within you know like
philosophy of mind um
but but i mean it's just very generic
right i mean just this idea that you
know what what are the what are the
necessary ingredients
um to make a decision
well you know i have to have some
beliefs about how the world is and i
have to have some desires about how the
world i would like it to be
and my intention involves integrating
those two things right and then and then
if all goes if all goes well in terms of
translating intentions into controlling
the body then i'll act out you know
something according to my intention
right i mean simple you know like the
dumb example that you'll often hear just
you know something like you know i
desire some ice cream
you know i believe that there's an ice
cream truck
you know down the road
you know given those two things and
and necessarily those two things right i
can inform and touch it and then form an
intention to go you know walk over the
ice cream truck and buy some ice cream
you know so i mean the question is how
else
you know are you going to explain why i
went over to the truck to buy the ice
cream it literally just is you know that
is the general sort of thing that when
we're reasoning about other people's you
know decisions other people's um
you know behavior and we're trying to
figure out okay why did this person do
what they did you know if we're assuming
it's a voluntary action right if we're
assuming it's not because like their
arms spasmed or you know because they
have some like really highly ingrained
habit or compulsion or something like
that right when we're talking about
voluntary behavior um that is just the
way right that that we tend to reason
about how people do what they do you
know either once when somebody does
something that's we think is weird
right then usually we have to explain
that in terms of okay well they just
believed something that was incorrect
right or or they had some really funny
desire right that i don't relate
um you know it tends to be you know one
of those sorts of things
right i mean i mean i don't know a lot
of other um
you know separate
uh folk psychological models that would
uh entail anything different than this
um you know at a very generic level um
and it's also
exactly the sort of thing
right that that people try to contrast
active inference with
where where instead of you know belief
desires beliefs and desires coming
together to form intentions instead it'd
be something like one kind of belief and
another kind of belief come together to
form an intention
um which again for a lot of reasons um
is
you know
confusing and rightfully so when it's
presented that way
thanks
yes
so ryan when
we've had some conversations with other
authors and other papers where we've
talked about the scale three formalism
and we've also talked a little bit about
the sort of scale friendly
uh
times when you have to find that history
and that context what you just mentioned
was sort of the generic
generalized sense that the bdi umbrella
provides you're not saying that
scale-free quantification and a generic
uh way of modeling something are the
same thing but what i think i'm like
without putting words in your mouth are
you saying that the scale freeness as it
moves to something more scale friendly
sweeps up some of that generic big tent
idea or model and now
moves it along it allows you to sort of
parse and be specific and precise
precise but also be able to generalize
as you move through those you know
quantifications of the just distribution
and density and such because that's kind
of what i was reading into it i just
want to make sure that i got it i was
kind of
maybe you can help me clean that up a
bit
um i mean i really don't know that
anything that we're saying uh really
depends on or even gets into a lot of
those sorts of specifics i mean really
and really all we're saying is is that
um you know if you want to take
um the model uh like the the current
active inference formulas and the
current kind of like vanilla formalism
right so in terms of an interested
standard one level palmdp or you know if
you want to scale it up hierarchically
it doesn't ultimately matter it is if
you want you use
um the vanilla active inference
framework to actually model some sort of
voluntary decision process in a human
right so i mean a lot of my work has to
do with people you know modeling
behavior on decision making tasks
right often have to do with you know the
person the person has the goal of
maximizing you know how much money they
win or you know maximizing some sort of
social reward something like that the
idea is just that when you're trying to
if you're gonna take an active inference
model and you're gonna use it to model
uh successfully model actual human
behavior when they're making decisions
then um
there's always gonna be
a mapping between the different elements
in the active inference model of
voluntary behavior
that or the whatever the prior you know
prior preference distribution is
you just check that so that it just
builds the level of reward
you know so so there's really nothing
about any
scale or anything like that this is much
more generic it's just if you're going
to use active inference to model
voluntary choice then
um it will always have
something analogous to a belief and a
desire because that's just what you need
right like to model to model voluntary
behavior
um it's true that you know that's
probably if you're if you actually were
going to try to capture
something
uh kind of like more of the actual
architecture in the brain as opposed to
just this kind of like
voluntary decision process aspect i mean
i'm sure there's a lot of kind of
hierarchy below that under the hood
right that's translating
more abstract policy selection processes
into whatever the dynamic signals are
that end up controlling you know moment
by moment muscle movements and things
like that
but the point is is the below
below this kind of top level where
you're doing policy selection
um
you know at that point you don't really
need the desires anymore right you just
need the policy to specify whatever the
motor commands are going down that can
take the form of predictions
um so so i don't i don't know if that
helps but it's just it's just that
there's a certain level in any kind of
hierarchy of a model that's going to
actually
be applicable successfully to human
behavior and
at the level of policy selection
um
prior preferences will just include the
the desired outcomes they'll just encode
the goals that the agent's trying to
reach and the policy that's chosen
will
be evaluated as being the most likely
policy
because it's the thing that's predicted
to
have the highest probability of um of
getting the desired you know generating
the desired uh observation
um
if i may also comment on that and
i'm not sure if this is
um answering your question dean but the
way i thought about it when i was
reading the paper uh was that part of
the reason why uh
the belief desire intention model kind
of uh
works uh works well for for mapping the
active inference ontology to the folk
psychology ontology is because it's a
discrete model in that it separates
these these different these different
parts and
and i think that also might have
motivated the choice to
consider mainly discrete pomdps
uh and describe the uh decision this
decision active inference in that um
in that way as well
um
because then this
discrete model
can be more easily mapped to
say the discrete model of
uh the pomdp that's this that's
described like a like a factory graph
i'm
i'm not sure
i
i was wondering how this would map to
continuous tasks as well it
well i mean i mean i think the i mean
part of the
i mean uh you know part of the part of
the reason why you need something
discreet
right is is because actions is discrete
right i mean there's either
one or there's policy two or this policy
right so those those just are sort of
necessarily
right i mean you get you know continuous
state spaces work well or are
appropriate
um you know at lower levels in a
hierarchy you know when you're talking
about kind of dynamics and motor
movement you know dynamics in the
setpoint of some reflex arcore or when
you're trying to estimate um
something in perception that you know
just just as a continuous quantity right
like brightness or you know orientation
or things like that but but the level of
um
at the level of decision making
um models are necessarily
right discreet
um i mean i mean there is
you know there are there are kind of
hybrid models right that are out there
in the literature you know like mama's
part for example you know has published
liberal papers using these sorts of
models where the the kind of policy
at the higher level which is which is in
a discrete model
uh generates right some observation that
then sets that point
right for some continuous or some
continuous lower level model that then
you know can end up in a in a way that's
kind of like this kind of
story you know like move the eyes around
the cod to different locations and
things like that um so um so i i
i kind of think that that the
discreteness is or the the
the reason why
um things move to a discrete state space
architecture is just because of like the
necessary
um what's necessary with respect to a
model of policy collection
um because it is kind of all or none
um
just to keep the dot zero zero-ish we're
gonna move a lot faster through the
following slides and there's many
important questions um in the chat and
and also arising so we're just gonna
carry on more rapidly so people can
pick up on these key points in the xero
and we'll have a lot of time to explore
soon
section two
from predictive coding to active
inference traces the uh history and the
development from
various fields
and just
one
sentence here that that dean and i both
highlighted on and then dino let you
describe the button was that um
crucially for the purposes of this paper
the first generation active inference
was not a theory of decision making it
did not explain how we decide or plan
where to move our body it only explained
how body movements can be executed using
the predictive coding apparatus once a
decision has been made so how did you
connect that to the bottom right yeah so
if you're on a if you're on a
some sort of a website and you have to
pass through to something my question
was based on that statement when the
expectation is
to know that you've actually
crossed a threshold you've moved beyond
one page and there's an expectation that
there's something that you validated or
confirmed or whatever
is the feedback that you received does
that have
how how does the person who's actually
expecting that
they're on the other side what kind of
feedback mechanism do they need to for
that confirmation is tactile
feedback enough do they need some sort
of a visual confirmation as well like
what is the
what's the
it is there because we're talking about
thresholds is that different for every
single person or is there sort of
expectations built in depending upon the
kind of situation that you're dealing
with
um i do know that with with the idea
that like changes are saved or links are
copied sometimes the click isn't enough
to give people confidence that in fact
that process is carried through
i mean i would i would say that i mean a
lot of those questions are really
empirical empirical questions as opposed
to modeling questions
um you know i mean i mean in terms of in
terms of how you would model that sort
of thing right you just specify what
observations count as tactile you
specify what observations count as
visual
and and uh
you know what ends up being thresholds
first efficient evidence and things like
that just just have to do with the way
that it processes just how the dynamics
naturally you know enroll um in the
model
under whatever the model
parameterization is you know so so um
you'll hit a threshold faster if the
mapping between observing whatever
observations and states is more precise
um for example
um i mean
there's uh you know in relation in
relation to that when we're doing policy
selection right we also have to check
and see whether things are actually
going as we expected them to go you know
under a choice of policy right so it's
possible that you choose policy one and
you start to get the subsequent
observations and they don't actually
match what you expected you know given
that you had chosen policy one
um you know in which case
um you'll update your beliefs through
perceptual inference and that might
influence how you act going forward
um so so but uh the specifics about you
know what's enough and whether it's
visual or tactile or anything like that
i mean those are those are really just
empirical questions um that would have
to be answered in studies as opposed to
something about model choices
okay so there was really not a good
enough thing when you did the dark room
aspect of it
like the rhythm that you were prepared
to take on
right like somebody was prepared to take
on the risk because they really urgently
wanted the ice cream versus the person
who was like
i'm i'm agnostic right so that's maybe
that's kind of what i was
this was on the second reading of your
paper right so i was kind of now back
filling from further down in the paper
so
well i'm into that
yeah we'll go in the order because we're
mentioning things that we haven't
brought up yet but let's continue on and
we'll return to that and ryan i i also
agree that in any specific case it's
going to be a model parameterization
some of these are very difficult to
answer in the abstract model selection
setting
here
the
distinction between motor active
inference and decision active inference
is introduced
and
i'll allow jakob to just convey one pass
what is the difference between motor
active inference and decision active
inference
um
so i'm not sure whether i can uh
say much that hasn't been said yet but
in a
[Music]
briefly the motor active inference
is
does well
as already mentioned it does not
consider design
desires in the
in the active inference and folk
psychological sense uh
as
um
was then connected in the in the paper
but
uh also it is my understanding that the
motor control version of active
inference is modeled uh continuously
like the models of uh
of
the movement of individual muscle
muscles which does not entail decision
making so it's modeled with um in
continuous time rather than in discrete
time
and the decision-making uh active as
uh ryan already said as well uh
is all about decision making so it
describes
the discrete process of decision making
with
uh prior beliefs
and preferences
and it can i and it can be modeled at
different different
levels of cognition as well which is
one thing that i'm still a bit uncertain
about how we can move
through these different layers while
still keeping the same mathematical
formulation
uh but i think we'll probably get to
that in the other slides
yep we're gonna continue with this um
distinction of m a i for motor active
inference and d a i
for the decision active inference
here we're showing some key sections
from the paper
and
some citations
i think we will
continue on without going into this
in depth but it describes some of the
specific model quantities
that are being
described in active inference formalism
and we're going to come to them when we
look at some equations in the coming
slides
in section 3
preliminary considerations
two broad points are uh introduced and
we might show um a second one on a later
slide
um
how can we think ryan about what is said
here that decision making ai models are
largely taken to describe sub-personal
non-conscious processes
um and also it was asked in the chat not
that we have to address it now by david
um has active inference produced a
single reasonable model of a qualia
so when we're thinking about this first
broad point that was made here
where
is experience and what is the
distinction between the personal and the
sub-personal in
dai um
well i mean so there's a couple
different questions you asked there and
i don't necessarily think they're
synonymous
so you know when you said i think the
first question you asked was something
about um
uh
has active inference provided some sort
of uh explanation or or model of um of
qualia that would be satisfactory um in
the strong sense so in the sense of the
sense of quality as an explanation for
like the hard problem of consciousness
then i think active inference is in the
same place as anyone else and that no
one has a good explanation for
for you know how to deal with the hard
problem of consciousness right i mean
like massive literature out there but um
i think everyone thinks it's just as
mysterious as ever
um so so no right i mean on the other
hand
um i mean you know myself and others you
know have published multiple papers
showing how you can successfully use
active inference models
to um to model conscious access
processes right so the distinction
between when the brain is representing
something unconsciously versus when it's
representing something consciously um
you know in that it can you know
self-report right what it's representing
um can use the information to make
voluntary choices
um and we've shown that those sorts of
models are able to um you know reproduce
uh like empirical results in like eeg
studies and fmri studies and things like
that
um that an and that also can make novel
neurophysiological predictions um some
of which seem like they um you know in
some subsequent work uh you know have um
like empirical support for those
predictions
um so so in terms of providing a um
you know uh what seems like a useful
account of the the processes associated
with what people self-report that they
consciously experience um and uh and the
brain basis for that i think active
inference has the at least the starting
you know the starting um starting point
for for being useful and explaining
those sorts of things but
you know
why one little posterior inside a model
versus another posterior in a model
actually corresponds to like the
experience of red versus blue or
something i mean no i don't i think
active inferences is
um not any better than anyone else you
know any other model for that question
um
the um the i guess the second thing you
know that you asked had to do with
um it's kind of like a related question
of you know why it's the case that one
level has to do with a conscious process
versus unconscious process and um
um the best i really got there and you
know what what falls out of the models
that we've um you know shown really just
has to do with temporal scale um you
know so there's though there will be a
certain level of temporal
representations in a hierarchical model
that um that integrates enough and
represents regularities over a long
enough time scale that it can contribute
to
you know sort of prospective um
um it'll be sufficiently compact to
generate things like self-reports right
so i mean think about how complicated
and temporally extended
um reporting and choosing to report
something like you know i see something
green with me right i mean it's a very
complicated temporally deep um you know
type of policy to select and requires
integrating a bunch of information from
stuff at lower levels that's happening
over faster time scales
um so at a minimum right you just need
to be at a level of representation where
the regularities are sufficiently uh
sufficiently long and um especially
temporarily deep and then have access to
all the relevant information you need to
integrate to be able to generate um
reports like that
um whereas whereas much of the other
kind of little pieces in the model right
like uh
you know the generated um say like
expected or for like variational for
energy gradients and things like that
that you know people might call like
surprise right i mean no one's claiming
that and often they will not relate in
any way to people's conscious reports
about feeling surprised because
conscious reports about feeling
surprised will have to do with
representations of surprises in states
right as opposed to
um you know some sort of prediction
error like uh you know gradient
minimization process
thanks
um
also in section three there are several
clarifications
um
and some
seeds that are planted
uh
namely if computational and folks
psychological predictions converge
and no other available theory can
account for behavior equally well this
could entail the mathematical structure
of dai
as more than a convenient tool instead
that it corresponds to the true
information processing structure
underlying and enabling folk psychology
and related abilities
and this is really
nicely put here that the crucial point
remains that one should not conflate
mathematical and psychological levels of
description
however dai models might nonetheless
offer more detailed information about
the true form of folk psychological
categories and processes
and then they add that their aims are to
demonstrate that there's a clear
isomorphism between the elements of dai
models and those of the bdi model
and then
show how
provided one does not assume probability
distributions in computational models
must be identified with beliefs at the
psychological level there will be no
tension between dai and bdi and that
comparison or juxtaposition is clarified
by
separating mai from dai like has been
mentioned
anything else before we start to jump
into some of the formalisms and keeping
all of this in mind
i guess i um i had one question on um
on the
on
which
um
ontology we're working with when we say
there's a isomorphism between the
elements of dai models and those of the
bdi model
um
because i think there are multiple ways
to interpret this uh
one one thing that i'm wondering about
is whether this means that we can
basically construct a mathematical
formulation of the of the bdi model that
is like a subset of active inference or
maybe
um
maybe there are certain certain elements
of the bdi model that aren't necessarily
encapsulated within actin that weren't
discussed in this paper and what
that would
um
mean in terms of
formulating
this
mathematical
mathematical formulation of of the bdi
model
so
i mean what the isomorphism just means
is
tell me the description at one level and
i'll be able to translate it for you
very quickly and directly into whatever
the description is at the other level in
both directions
right i mean so it just means you know
tell me tell me what you know tell me
what it is that you want you know if i
say do you want ice cream or do you want
a pizza right tell me tell me that you
like if you tell me that you like you
want pizza twice as much as you like ice
cream
then it's very easy to just put
you know
a four
you know in the you know in the in the
distribution you know in the preference
distribution over the observation of
pizza and the two for ice cream
and then softmax it and log it right and
then
like you know there's that's the
description
right so just in a very direct way just
encodes relative desires for one thing
versus another you know tell me what
your beliefs are right i mean do you
believe that pizza is to the left or to
the right i can put that in as the
different categories of hidden states
that you're getting for a distribution
over right so like it's just the point
is that in either direction right give
me the full psychological description
i can translate it very
straightforwardly um using the same
elements every time as being desires or
beliefs
um you know give it to me at the uh
at the mathematical level i can
translate that into a description in
terms of beliefs and desires right i
mean it's just it's just one-to-one
um i can't think of an example of hand
um
where um there would be any kind of like
mismatch or an ability for one to um
account for the other but
um you know it's kind of hard to prove a
negative right so i mean maybe you can
give me an example but i can't think of
one
awesome
jacob
yeah i was just gonna say that i can't
really think of an example uh right now
um
i
i just found i found it really
interesting with the usage of uh
of just the word isomorphism because
that
like as you as you said it's just
a bi-directional subjective map so it's
basically equivalent it's just set in a
different way
so i can imagine that uh
meaning that we can basically
instead of the wikipedia page for the
bdi model uh using all of these
terms uh um
like believe desire intention it could
just be a set of active inference
equations and that's the bdi model
because it's an isomorphism
right
literally your your beliefs are just
your cues
right and
your uh and your desires are just your
uh you know pfos
right i mean and i mean in the you know
the way that we've uh you know we and
others have tended to write it now
right is to literally just explicitly to
say like that desires are um or the
preference distribution is p of o given
c
right where c is just a matrix that
defines your preferences right so i mean
it's a lot clearer to do that um
than to just just leave it just p of o
right i think that's part of the
confusion is that uh it's not clear
where the preferences come from but
they're just it's just because their
condition on this other thing c
and c can be fixed or learnt but that's
the basis of the calculation there
yeah
here we get into section four
variational and expected free energy
considerations
and in large script we see the
variational free energy equation
dean
what is the skydiver doing
and during the one and the two
we'll unpack more about the exact terms
and and what is um coming into and
coming out of this equation but just as
an appetizer here what's the skydiver
doing
well now i've got the author here i i
just put through that in there because i
like that
i don't think it's a metaphor but the
analogy of of how so how do you respond
when you jump out of the airplane and
you know your parachute's not going to
work do you uh
do you go head first and really attack
it or like what now what are you doing
in terms of
what your expectations are so maybe
maybe
that that that was a good analogy ryan
maybe what like so where were you where
were you going with that because
yeah
well i mean i think the point the point
of those sorts of examples are just uh
just to um
sorry to put this to to show
why
it's not um
it's not really correct to think about
the um
like prior uh you know this prior
preference distribution even though it's
you know it's again it's cast as a prior
belief right
um it's not really appropriate to think
about that as a
as a um
a belief per say right i mean
the um or an expectation at any at a
psychological level of description um so
you can and the way to contrast that
right is you could say look like the
person
in a model where they don't want
right to fall to the ground and die
right that would be
your your yeah that would be your pia
though right it's your preference not to
have the observation of hitting the
ground and dying
but what you act
right
is is your q of o given pi right it's
what do i expect to observe given that i
choose this policy versus that policy
right so that's the that's the you know
the leafy part right it's what i expect
given that i do this or that and you
know how close is that to how much does
that diverge from
what i what i want right which would be
your pfl
um so it's just it's just a clear
example of how your
you know your belief the expectations
and your desire the expectations come
apart
and that and it just doesn't work
conceptually i think one is think of one
as like the same kind of uh
uh kind of thing as the other
yeah i i just thought as if i'm not
going to get a soft landing how big of a
crater can i
can i create
well that's that then is going to be
packed into your preference distribution
right
right you would have some desire for you
know to make a big you know conditional
on you're going to die right like like
you know you'd prefer right to make a
big crater than a small crater
and that would still just go in your pfo
right so yeah yeah
um
jakub
um i was just wondering um and this
might be me uh
thinking thinking
or not too deeply about the equation uh
rather but in this in this formulation
where it's a variational free energy for
each policy f of pi
um does that does that imply when in the
last sentence on this slide that uh free
energy is a function of beliefs
and a function of observations that
doesn't mean that the free energy is
essentially a function of three
variables
uh but in this case we are only writing
it f of pi because
uh it's always imp it's it's clear that
it's a functional of beliefs and
observations
um
or
should we think of it more as
just a function of
each policy
um i mean the way it's written here i
mean i think that the most preferred way
to think about it is i mean it literally
just means that um using this equation
you will calculate a different f value
for each policy
right i mean that's really it like you
just there will be
you're going to be computing
some some variational for energy value
for each policy and that's going to make
up a distribution over policies
um and um and uh i mean the
the the tricky thing i guess here is is
that um
you know this isn't about
this isn't you know f of f of pi here
isn't about making decisions right this
is just about you know something like
evaluating evidence for
um you know for various policies one
because you you can't you calculate f
when you already have the observation
right so you can't really do this
perspective decision making thing with f
um so this is just basically a way of
describing how um
how under each policy your beliefs will
change uh or wouldn't change right under
when you know when you get conditional
in each new observation that you get
um
and um and so it's not uh yeah so all it
denotes really is is just you know you
have a value of f for each policy and
that makes it a distribution
and that takes us to
g
expected free energy the letter after f
and
as shown here not sure if there's
another reason for why it's g
um this is
equation 2.6 from the active inference
textbook just for reference with some
other versions of how g is framed
g
is a prospective value
and they write decision making does not
only require beliefs about past and
present states
it also requires making predictions
about future states and future
observations
this requires taking the average i.e
expected free energy g of pi given
anticipated outcomes under each policy
that one might choose
and there's um
a lot to say on expected free energy
what is just one short note that
somebody could add
or ryan why was it placed here
um i'm not sure i understand the
question
like why what
why is why is expected free energy
required why is variational free energy
not enough
i mean expected free energy is just is
just what the system's trying to
minimize when it's selecting a policy
right so i mean it's just trying to i
mean in this i mean this decomposition
right here is often called like the risk
risk with ambiguity decomposition but
um
i guess uh
i like i think that i think that showing
the um you know the risk term the risk
term here provides a
nice kind of intuition for um for again
the separation between beliefs and
desires and active inference because
um you know you're
you're uh so the
the term underlined in in red there
right so the kale divergence between q o
given pi and p of l
right i mean that's just saying
that um you know how different
are the observations i expect given that
i'd use a given policy
and you know how different how how
different is that
how different do i expect that to be
from
my uh my preferences are my desires
right pfl
um so the the closer those are together
right
the more uh the more similar i expect
the observations to be under a policy
to my preferred observations the smaller
that's going to be
and so if i'm trying to select the
policy that minimizes
uh g
right then that means i'm going to
select the policy that's going to get me
as close that's going to get me as close
to my preferred observations as possible
right so literally just is that kl
divergence literally just is trying to
choose the policy that brings beliefs
closest to desires
very nice and then what does the blue
term mean
uh that's just an entropy term right so
i mean it's just basically saying that
the is what drives information seeking
or part of what drives information
seeking it's just uh
it's just yeah basically the agents
choose you know driven to choose
policies that also are going to generate
more precise expected observations
observations that are going to
disambiguate states more more easily
great
um here we'll explore it more in the dot
one but there's a a description of the
posterior probability distribution over
policies p of pi
and an expression involving the soft max
symbol with the sigma we'll return to
that later but this is just so that we
can cover like the key experiments and
the simulation results today
this is also one other
area of formalism we can explore in the
coming discussions
about precision and the relationship of
beta and gamma and what the convergence
towards means
but we won't go there there is precision
parameter in this model
let's go to the dark room problem and
many
lines of pdf screen and ink has been
written on the dark room
in the active world since um perhaps
first in at all 2012
and also outside of active
and um
they write in a nutshell the concern is
that if agents only act to minimize
prediction error
as opposed to acting under the impetus
of a cognitive desire-like state
then
they ought to simply seek out very
stable predictable environments such as
a dark room and stay there
would anybody like to add anything about
this dark room problem or what is the
relationship between doxastic and
cognitive
ontology
and active
i mean are you just asking what like
what those words mean or what like how
do you how do you use these words
i mean i mean detoxastic is just a term
that refers to you know the leafy you
know like epistemic sorts of things
right so so a doxastic ontology would be
an ontology that includes beliefy things
right whereas whereas
uh you know conative just refers to
yeah being like targeted towards
something right like something about you
know desires or um
um
you know something things you want
versus don't want things you like versus
don't like right so um it's just uh you
know when we say it's apparently purely
a duck tastic ontologist just saying
it might look as though superficially
like the um the ontology proposed an act
of inference like the things that exist
in active inference are purely beliefy
yeah that's all that means
great and it's applied in the setting of
this dark room
um for the following two slides
dean
help us understand what concerns are
addressed and what the child on the top
right of the slide is doing
yeah well so
i'm not going to go through all all of
the text but essentially this was my
introduction to the darkroom problem
because it was kind of the opposite of
all my experience which is that i
tend to find people that were curious
and we're trying to move away from
information
um
leveling offers
or being static to information gain so
first of all i had to learn what what
the what the argument was about why
people would actually in it who are
normally social why they would move away
from that social realm and into this
sort of dark space
under the con under the idea that
active inference actually implies that's
what people would do
um and then secondly it was i was kind
of trying to tie it into the idea of
the refrigerator and where it is and and
until you actually and then danny you
and i talked about this a bit the
pragmatic piece of until you actually
open the refrigerator
door which is on the kind of the next
slide you don't really i mean you can
have a belief that there's something of
value in there but it can turn out that
when
you open the door or monty raises the
curtain the thing that you were
expecting uh turns out to be a value but
not necessarily of that thing that you
were
you were setting yourself up to believe
and so
that
that young individual spitting the coin
out um
maybe i guess i was just trying to be a
little bit facetious there that it holds
value but it doesn't hold the same kind
of um
tasty value of say having a lick of an
ice cream cone so
again it was
it was trying to move away from the idea
that
the beliefy stuff alone
is satisf
satisfactory or
necessary i i always get those two mixed
up but i think i i was just trying to
reinforce the idea that you kind of need
to have both so that you can compare and
contrast so that you get a sense of what
a person or what an agent is doing
as they're getting past some of those
shrouds or some of those
um
non-observables into the observable
state
thanks we'll keep going
um
this is unpacking some of the concerns
about the apparent pure doxastic
belief-oriented ontology of actin so
ryan described earlier like is it about
beliefs colliding and if so if it's
purely doxastic then where is this um
desire
and um
[Music]
is there anything else that anybody
wants to add here
i would maybe um
comment that i think this also relates
to
uh your
um to the earlier thing that was
discussed how this confusion might stem
from people um misinterpreting
or um mis
uh confusing the terms predictive
processing and active inference
um
and i feel like this addresses it as
well where if we just if it's only
beliefs
uh
then there is obviously a concern that
once we're in a dark room
we
uh
can't because uh
if we're only in the regime of
predictive processing there is no way
for us to
move to a different state
or there isn't the formalism that that
describes
planning and action
um
but
as
i guess we'll get to in the other slides
when we do include this
planning
we suddenly have
desire like terms appearing within the
mathematical formulation as well
great
yeah i want to be clear it's not like
they're thrown in at hawk right they
emerge naturally as like necessary
components of any kind of
you know like using this sort of
framework or building it out to involve
planning so it's not a like that they
emerge naturally and necessarily it's
not a it's not because someone's just
kind of tacking them on
great um and this is referring to that
minimization of g
the minimization of g
drives the agent to seek out
observations that will reduce
uncertainty about the best way to
subsequently bring about phenotype
congruent or preferred outcomes
so that's the information seeking
another way to put this is that under
dai an agent doesn't simply seek to
minimize prediction error with respect
to its current sensory input it seeks
instead to minimize prediction error
with respect to its global beliefs about
the environment which entails seeking
out observations that are expected to
generate prediction errors
such that uncertainty is minimized for
the generative model as a whole
and
another aspect of this type of global
prediction error minimization process is
that it pertains not only to beliefs
about states in the present but also to
beliefs about the past and in the future
and so this is leading to one of the
claims which is that in addition to
desires
dai captures folk
psychological experiences associated
with the drive to both know about one's
current states
and learn what will happen when choosing
to move to other states among other
parameters in a generative model
let's go into this generative model and
come to the dark room simulation itself
um
and we'll
unpack it more
in future times
but the prior over policies e of pi
they write that um
when the agent repeatedly chooses a
policy this term increases the
probability that the agent will continue
to select that policy in the future at
the level of the formalism this
corresponds to an agent coming to expect
that it will choose a policy
simply because it has chosen that policy
many times in the past
this can be thought of as a type of
habitization process but it doesn't have
any direct connection to preferred
outcomes because e of pi is not informed
by other beliefs in the agent's model so
here's the partially observable markov
decision process just one representation
of it and e is sort of floating there
influencing but not being influenced by
and we had some interesting discussions
which we can return to another time
about how we might be able to assess
whether somebody is engaging in a
behavior because they simply have
habitually
engaged in that behavior
but they understand the actual mapping
of how
policies um relate to outcomes
or in another case where somebody might
be engaging in a behavior not because of
habitualization but rather because they
have um some sort of
deviation from the appropriate mapping
between policies and outcomes
and maybe there's other ways so i
thought that was very interesting how
even within the same
sort of sparse and first principles
model similar behavioral outcomes might
be observed
on like a behavioral manifold
and then
different kinds of perturbations or
evaluations might reduce uncertainty
about what is giving rise to those
conversion behaviors in in that case
um okay dean with the ice cream truck
and the eye
no i'm gonna i'm gonna wait because i
think that's i think this one and that
and the next one are better to take up
in a one two part because
because if if ryan can come back there's
some good questions i want to ask him
about those
two sections because this slide and the
next one
are kind of anti
uh dark room
and so
i want to kind of pick his brain about
what you know how we can sort of
convince people that that that dark room
problem is for such a small subset of
the population that majority of
the stuff that we're talking about here
is done in in
sort of social settings and social
context and there's a third party
sometimes it can observe an observer and
what role that plays
in trying to figure out what's what's
going on here as we move from the
from the idea of decisioning
and and so forth so i'll wait
great so here's part one of that
and here's part two
looking at uh social learning theory a
little bit
but let's go to
the figure and to the simulation
uh this is figure one simulation of an
active inference agent deciding whether
to eat some ice cream
and um
there's various ways to go about
describing it but one of the key pieces
that anyone can give a remark about what
is occurring here
is that there's three cases that are
being compared
there's a no desire case
a weak desire
reflected by this
p of o
and a strong desire case where the ratio
between the two alternatives between um
wanting the ice cream and or between the
ice cream state and the no ice cream
state is a sharper distinction in this
second row
so there's a case in which ice cream is
in the fridge but where the kitchen is
currently dark and so the agent doesn't
know whether the fridge is to the left
or right
so it's like a tea maze
setup
with three possible cases
one where there's no preference for
observing ice cream or not a weak or a
strong preference for that
and then
under these situations
we can ask about what happens in terms
of the action
as well as the um beliefs and valence
updates
what else would you add about that ryan
well i mean i think the point you know
the point of this is just to show
well i guess makes a couple you know i
mean so dean mentioned that
um you know the issue with the dark room
right i mean as he said i mean as you
said i mean this is essentially just a a
particular very similar to
to like a team is right i mean just
putting a putting a different sort of
semantics on top of it
but the you know but the idea is just
that um
it's just
set up to show that
you know even without any kind of desire
right just just resolving uncertainty um
the agent will be driven to leave a dark
room or do something to get rid of the
dark room
um so you don't need a desire right but
but in fact any realistic agent is also
going to have desires so
um so in the case where there are
desires then there's two different
reasons
why
um no active inference agent will ever
stay in a dark room or be motivated to
stand a dark room like in all cases
it will have a motivation
to to leave so i mean the point is just
to show right in some explicit
simulations that um generically right
like the this kind of dark room problem
um
just will it will just never apply um to
active inference
um again the stark room thing only
applies if you assume the thing is just
doing something like predictive coding
but then somehow also assume that it's
making decisions
um
but that's not active inference um
because it's not a theory of decision
making
awesome
um here is some description about the
strength of the desire
could have been shown before the figure
but we wanted to introduce the the
simulation setting
and as described there is um
a desire
as well as an information seeking and i
believe that's the two reasons why the
agent will escape the dark room and
there's there's other escape hatches
depending on how one constructs their
model um
potentially like a hierarchical model
might have a slightly different
um explanation for why an agent does or
doesn't stay in the room but even just
within this single level model there's
an information seeking as well as a
preference realizing
reason
um
any other comments here
okay
dean
just a quick thing
baby in the island i'll put you in the
island go for it yeah uh so maybe ryan
just just a just a quick this last last
couple of senses however preference
distributions are set to zero oh i'm
sorry i'm not still on the previous
slide daniel sorry can you go back one
yeah go for it
okay so however if preference
distributions are set to zero as in our
no desire simulation such that no
outcome is desired over any other net
and active inferences will nonetheless
be driven to choose
behaviors that will maximize information
gain okay that all makes sense that's
just the background
this is the part i was curious about
while this might reasonably be
considered a motivational influence it
is
basically less plausible that it should
be considered cognitive
and may therefore be better seen as a
type of doctastic drive
here the formalism may therefore help us
to recover and potentially nuance
the folk psychological distinction
between desire and curiosity these types
of drives seem to differ fundamentally i
agree with you but i was wondering if
you could maybe
explain why that
should be
something that we should keep separate
the idea of desire and curiosity i know
you go into explaining it a little more
into the paper but
why did you want to point that out to
readers
well i mean i think there's a couple
things i mean i mean one i think that
you know these things are both driving
you know decisions about what to do
right so in some way they motivate they
both motivate behavior right but but at
the same time
you know and i think uh this is
something you know that alex keeper and
you know pointed out when we were
writing this as opposed to just you know
so it's not just me
um but you know pointed out that um you
know there is this kind of
um
fairly clear difference um between the
this uh you know curiosity or
epistemically driven um sort of behavior
um from the kind of desire-driven
behavior and the the
the kind of clear differences is the vm
this epistemically driven motivation
isn't um it isn't driven toward anything
right it doesn't have a target it's not
trying to get one thing versus another
um
all it's trying to do is just
you know just become clearer about
what's out there um essentially right so
so the fact that it lacks a target um is
really i think what makes the what makes
the distinction clear
um
but the i mean beyond that i think
motivation was just a was just to show
that um
you know like just a
you know generically right like the
belief desire intention principle
doesn't really um
doesn't really say anything about uh
you know types of types of desires
there's nothing really explicitly just
in that very very simple um
way of um
describing the framework that that
separates out
uh information seeking from from rewards
to gang right um so
you know so you could right if all
you're doing
is trying to you know compare active
inference to um
do
you know the bdi model very simply
stated then um then this is able to kind
of nuance a little more right like
different different things that that um
might look like you know promotive
motivational
kinds of things
[Music]
but there are separated those um
on you know why decisions are made for
one thing versus another more kind of
tied to beliefs in a different way
um you know that being said i mean at
the same time i think that um you know
like full psychology
more
more broadly i think i think uh very
intuitively and naturally um does you
know recognize the difference between
things like curiosity
right and things like and things like
reward-driven behavior right those are
concepts that we have just in our
natural kind of folk psychology um you
know so active inference just captures
those right i mean
i um
yeah i talked about this um just as an
example of you know how intuitive i
think and like natural the sort of
aspect is you know and i just like think
of like most of the behaviors that say
like my little dog does
um you know if i look at if i look at
what my dog does
90 of the time it's way more information
seeking than it is reward seeking you
know
she searches out for some food a couple
times a day but i take her in the car
she's pulling left and right to see
what's out the window and how that
changed all the time you know any little
sound perks up looks right none of those
things are reward driven they're all
just information seeking
um so i mean very very clearly that's a
big part of
you know what drives
us and other animals to do um so so the
point was just to just to kind of show
that active inference captures that in a
certain sense it adds some granularity
to um to at least what the bdi model
says but but in that case the bdi model
is kind of too uh too coarse grained and
i think normal hulk psychology doesn't
include those things already
great
um
also to be returned to dean
yeah because ryan just basically
answered it all these two images are
basically doing is separating out the
sort of goal directed from the
curiosity which is
you know the the image on the right is
basically a documentary about the
franklin expedition where
they were going out to the event horizon
but they never returned
so
did they have a goal probably but was
that their curiosity being carried out
i think we i think we've got to be able
to make sure that we appreciate both so
that's all i wanted
this makes me think like um
are you driven to watch the sunset over
the horizon
or are you driven to find out what's at
the end of the rainbow and what's over
the horizon
and that's the sort of like infinite
open-ended curiosity drive beyond the
horizon
versus the preferred
specific state that one can desire in
terms of their
um observations and reduce the
divergence there but
cool
um
wishful thinking we'll come back to
we're just leaving notes so that we can
um
have more to discuss later because these
are all like
there's such vital threads um
ryan and maxwell and alex
because they um
touch to our
day-to-day experience
in a way that
few other um
frameworks and and even papers within
active do so affect and the role of
affect and precision curiosity these are
all just like
terms that
touch humans
um
one thing that i you know that i think
is probably worth just touching
animating is something maybe you guys
would want to talk about in the future
you know maybe when i'm not around the
other any other sections not sure but
um you know uh so there is a probably a
distinction that's worth keeping in mind
between uh curiosity per se
and um and goal-directed information
seeking um i think some of the you know
examples you guys have mentioned have
been more kind of along the lines of one
versus the other so i think it might be
good to just just keep that distinction
clear that um you know in in vanilla
active inference um it is really
something more just kind of like
curiosity just kind of like
independently driven just kind of you
know look where you're going to get the
most information
um whereas you know the construct of
directed exploration
um you know and reinforcement learning
and um and what also you know often
something that can emerge i think a
little more clearly and like
sophisticated active inference um
is um you know as information seeking
specifically or you know in the service
of knowing you know how to get your goal
um
you know the the the curiosity version
that we're showing here
it has the effect of helping the agent
get what it wants
but
but the drive to seek out information
isn't actually itself
due to the fact that the agent thinks it
will help it get its goal
you know it's just driven to seek the
information independently
whereas um whereas uh in in other
yeah like in sophisticated inference um
the
agent is actually doing something more
like i'm going to look over here because
i think looking over here is actually
going to help me get to what i want
better right so this is kind of
strategic information seeking and that's
that's a little different than just like
intrinsic curiosity so um just something
to keep clear
that's quite interesting it kind of
ties a braid back
but let's explore that later
um here
we have a nice
uh clean representation of the summary
of the main argument
their proposed solution is somewhat
deflationary
in the sense that it simply argues that
the functional role of desire
not the experience of desire is
straightforward
straightforwardly present in the dai
formalism and then in more detail they
argue that and they provide four points
which it'll be great to go over with
with the authors
based on those considerations the
apparent problem posed by purely
doxastic looking constructs is simply
not a problem
there are beliefs and desires in the
active inference framework
um
perhaps we could have uh explored this
more with the formalism so we'll bring
it up to uh talking more about f
but won't go into it now we'll return to
the letters later
and then the appendix is uh very
informative
there's a description of all the states
and the factors that are used in the
simulation
and in the model stream one which is by
the way ryan it's um
our our most popular
series was model stream one
it was it was uh
it was a fan favorite
but um
it's some similar
concepts and matlab scripts so the
appendix describes how the
figure one
results were generated and maybe we'll
see if anybody can run that and execute
it we can play with a few different
things and
take some of these qualitative
linguistics and
even mutate the simulation a little bit
see where that takes us
we'll close out with our usual closing
slide
um so
who would like to take the first last
word
yes dean then yeah then ryan first of
all thanks for uh shepherding us these
three cats through this uh paper because
there's an awful lot of stuff to try to
cover in a
pretty short period of time and it was
and it's easy i think to sort of go
i don't want to say tangentially but go
deeper into some of the parts of the
paper because um
uh for me it was one of those ones where
you i would go back and and have to
reflect on something after i read a
section and then try to fit it into the
larger picture that was
ryan i think the paper
did a very good job of sort of ordering
through what you were trying to say in
terms of the reassurance of how
the the quantitative
uh and the the modeling of the
psychosocial
could be
seen as working with each other as
opposed to though this doesn't answer
what this other thing questions but it
does cause this is this was a paper that
for me i won't speak for the others but
i had to read the section and then try
to plug it back into the overall
narrative that was being told and again
i think part of that is because the the
translation from the
stuff that's typically seen as
the quantitative part is hard to
move into the qualitative part i think
that's that's a challenge for anybody
that tries to move back and forth
between those two things but uh
yeah i mean in terms of
in terms of making a case and and
providing what i think people need to
sort of see the two in the same light
thank you appreciate it
sure i'm happy i'm happy if it's helpful
yeah i think um
[Music]
i guess there are two points that i
like to touch on firstly
i think i thought it was very helpful to
map these folks these concepts that
everyone even though everyone uh i guess
that's
the nature of psychology that everyone
will have a slightly
slightly different um probably
distribution on of what they these terms
actually mean but i think it's in just
learning about active inference it's
helpful to link the math
mathematical formulation and even just
the active inference ontology which
itself can be
very cumbersome at times to these very
um intuitive concepts
and i think as
we get we're starting to explore
modeling
within the actin flap as well i think
it's it will be really helpful to
use
this
isomorphism between active inference and
folk psychology to explain
the the behavior of agents within these
models and
not
beyond a dark room problem when there is
some unexpected behavior of an agent we
can directly look at okay how how did
um
this tensor change its values and
describe it with
this uh
psycho psychological ontology so i i
think personally that's
uh the most exciting thing about this
paper for me um
[Music]
yeah
well here i mean if that's i mean if
that's the kind of thing that you're
interested in then
i mean that's kind of the whole um
it's kind of the whole motivation of you
know for instance like computational
psychiatry right which is like the area
that i currently work in right you you
take for instance clinical populations
where people may behave in unexpected or
ways or ways that don't necessarily seem
like they're all that adaptive right
then you can just fit these models to
their behavior and you can figure out
okay well what is making their behavior
abnormal right is it is it something
about an overly precise preference
distribution or is it something about
um
you know
the belief that states uh states
transition to uh to um into volatile or
uncertain away or you know things like
that so i mean it is the yeah i mean the
kind of uh you know the major point is
you can use these novels in empirical
studies to figure out what the
mechanisms are that are leading to
healthy and unhealthy behavior um and
that can
give you kind of guiding information
toward you know designing better
treatments or you know trying to measure
these things in a more quantitative way
things like that and um and the uh you
know and just as i've said i mean this
is all
um using
using tasks that uh you know that
involve some kind of goal right like
seeking some kind of reward or social
approval or you know whatever it is that
you know humans seek out you could do
that right unless you have a
straightforward way to map
um the formalism each element of the
formalism to
you know the reason that we think people
behave in the way that they do right so
so on so i guess i'm just saying if if
that's an interest of yours then i would
think that you would um you'd probably
be a fan of a lot of the a lot of the
computational psychiatry literature more
broadly both you know both the active
inference part which is a lot of what my
lab does but but also just the broader
um computational psychiatric community
that uses reinforcement learning and
drift fusion models and all the other
from you know all the other classics
that are out there
cool and it opens it up to
what
organizations want and what do cells
want and all these other
um
transpositions
well ryan really appreciate that last
minute um
belief or desire
combination thereof
to join us it certainly helped
resolve our uncertainty a lot and it's a
great conversation
in the coming two weeks we're gonna be
with hopefully some more authors and
more lab participants and just
i'm looking forward to taking some notes
thank you see you all soon and bye
you